ils sont mieux armés plus rapides le
seul moyen d'arriver à arrêter ce gang
sauf flag [ __ ] où tu vas New York
c'est que si James night ne craquait pas
les braqueurs de banque il
Nike est un peu brut de décoffrage mais
c'est un bon policier c'est un gang
vraie équipe tu as une théorie c'était
appartient à une société écran qui
s'appelle wina
j'espère qu'on vous a pas interrompu
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour vous tu
connais plein d'anciens sportifs
professionnels je cherche des gars qui
en fait
ça vous rappellerait
la tête
le FBI la CIA la TF ont des enquêtes en
cours sur winna et de petits flics de
Los Angeles débarquent en pensant qu'ils
vont le coincer c'est le lieu de non
James Edward Knight et semble avoir des
sanctions disciplinaires au moins une
fois par an je réfléchis et si on
suivait ta méthode
le cavalier et la pièce la plus
dangereuse de l'échiquier peut frapper
quand vous vous y attendez le moins
[Musique]
c'est une blague
je peux te faire descendre où je veux et
quand je veux
[Musique]
être au mauvais endroit au bon moment à
tous les
coups tellement de
détails
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les bonbons ou un sort